[Music]
thanks for being here
oh thank you so much for having me I'm
always impressed you nailed my name
perfectly it's not an easy name well do
you have the experience where people
mispronounce it a lot well I was in
Montreal recently and my friend Jonah
Jonah ray and I do a show together
before the show the sound guy comes up
to me he's like what's your name I'll
introduce you and were like wall
his name's Jonah and my name is Kumail
and he's like got it goes out on stage
very confidently please welcome to the
stage Jonas and camel I was like you
have to know that that's the one word
that is not my name there's no way my
brown parents saw their Brown baby and
we're like are you thinking what I can
bow right you travel around quite a bit
you're doing comedy of you have you been
where we've been recently it's been
exotic and fun I was in Singapore
recently and something happened that
changed my life forever
oh yeah oh it's good dude did you get
the shots no oh well you'll know someone
kind of shot
I used a bidet for the first time
what that is a kind of shot yeah yeah
you had never used a bidet that's
amazing why is this not the only thing
anyone he's ever talking about like from
now on my life will be divided into two
sections before every years of the day
and the age of enlightenment how does it
how does it know exactly where to go
isn't everybody different like deceptor
is that the knowing touch of an old
lover it went right okay so so you're in
Singapore and you use a bidet
yeah and it became the greatest
experience of your life yeah yeah I mean
the first sound I made was a lot like
your impression of a falcon
[Applause]
so so no I don't you've never used it
with day I know what maybe I don't think
so I think I have used I think I thought
it was a bidet and it was a broken
toilet I am jealous I wish I could use
one for the first time really oh yes so
you had a good experience so aren't you
a big deal go out and get yourself a
bidet you could get one and have it in
your home can't you well I rent I can't
that's an awkward conversation with my
landlord like hey good news bad news
made some improvements I have a filthy
butthole so wonderful yeah isn't it
amazing that after all these years life
still has the capacity to surprise you
you know in the beginning and I was like
in the bathroom for so long in Singapore
just like you I was in the beginning I
was using it to feel clean and then I
was using it just to feel like myself
[Laughter]